[Music]
thank you very much everybody
I'd like to begin by saying that we just
completed a meeting with the Secretary
of Treasury Steve minuchin and Secretary
of Transportation Elaine Chao on
proposals regarding the airlines and the
airline business and we're very working
very closely with a lot of different
people will be probably putting out a
proposal and giving them some of the
details from some of the very powerful
details over the weekend it's moving
along quickly the airline business has
been hit very hard as everybody knows
and we are going to be in a position to
do a lot to help them so that they keep
their employees and they save their
businesses and that'll be taking place I
think you can say over the weekend we
may even have discussions with some of
the airlines or all of the airlines over
the weekend and I think it's going to be
a very very acceptable package it's a
very big package and a very acceptable
package it'll be good for our country
good for the airlines good for a lot of
people likewise I just spoke with the
president of Russia Vladimir Putin and
the king of Saudi Arabia King Salman and
we had a big talk as to oil production
and OPEC and making it so that our
industry does well and the oil industry
does better than it's doing right now
it's the numbers are so low that
there'll be layoffs all over the world
they'll be certainly layoffs in this
country we don't want that to happen we
built a great great energy
business in the United States so we have
tens of thousands of jobs we had a very
good
talk we'll see what happens but as you
know OPEC met today and I would say
they're getting close to a deal we'll
soon find out so that was a conversation
we just had so we've had a busy hour and
a half and let me begin by expressing my
sincere gratitude to the American people
millions of Americans are making
profound and difficult sacrifices in
their own lives because they know it
will save the lives of countless others
and that's exactly what it's doing you
see what's happening and where we are
where we stand and hopefully we're going
to be opening up we can quote opening
very very very very soon I hope together
our people are writing one of the most
noble chapters in the proud history of
our nation Americans are also encouraged
to learn that Boris Johnson Prime
Minister has been moved out of intensive
care that's a tremendous statement and
we continue to pray for him and his fast
recovery that's a very very positive
development as the New York metropolitan
area continues its battle against the
outbreak the full power of the federal
government is there to support them as
you know the Javits Center has now been
fully converted into a 3,000 bed
hospital one of the largest anywhere in
the country and by the incredible
professionals I have to say the the
Corps of Engineers what they can do is
just incredible they've done a fantastic
job in their building nationwide 21
temporary hospitals and care facilities
adding 17,000 hospital beds and they did
that all within a very short period of
time it's incredible what they've done
Army Corps of Engineers and FEMA has
been fantastic
our sweeping airlift operation to keep
doctors and nurses supplied with
protective equipment project air bridge
continues to expand with more than 24
flights already completed and 49
additional flights now scheduled in the
near future so that's been very
successful in that gear and those
outfits are being handed out as they
arrived they're going directly to point
the American medical system continues to
perform beyond our
expectations reminding us that the
United States is blessed with the most
advanced healthcare and the most skilled
health care workers anywhere in the
planet other countries are looking to
what we're doing and our testing
operation has now become far and away
the most sophisticated and the best
anywhere and we want to thank all of the
heroes or the frontlines as they fight
to save American lives we're at the top
of the hill pretty sure we're at the top
of the hill and now we're going downward
in some cases we've already started that
process earlier today I spoke with
hundreds of mental health leaders and
advocates from around the country to
discuss the vital work and the vital
work they're doing we had the top
doctors in the country some
international doctors mental health a
big factor not only as the virus
inflicted immense physical suffering on
many people but also mental and
emotional suffering as well even though
we're staying physically apart no
American is alone and we're all in this
together
but the mental health doctors and
experts a very great call it was a very
interesting call they're working very
hard we're also seeing encouraging signs
in our race to develop breakthrough
treatments and therapies Pfizer revealed
today that it has found a promising new
treatment that might prevent the virus
from replicating and that hopes it hopes
to begin testing in clinical trials very
soon it's going to be very very soon
they have great great feelings for this
particular therapy and they think that a
lot of good things are happening through
the FDA's coronavirus treatment
acceleration program 19 therapies and
treatments are now being tested and 26
more are in the active planning or
clinical trial so we have 19 therapies
being tested currently and 26 more are
in the active planning for clinical
trials that's a big statement that's a
lot trials for
gilli adds anti rival drug remedy severe
continued and the company has also
expanded emergency used for new patients
getting good early results by the way
the companies that manufacture
hydroxychloroquine are massively ramping
up production as you know many people
are recommending strongly z-pak be
headed the z-pak and also zinc and the
federal government continues to build
our stockpiles and distribute millions
of doses for doctors to use as they see
fit and i'm pleased to inform you we're
just having a lot of good things are
happening but we'll have to see how that
all works out but we have we've
purchased and we have stockpiled
millions and millions of doses and we're
distributing it some states wanted very
badly
Michigan we just sent a lot to Michigan
and other areas reporting today that we
passed two million tests completed in
the United States first time most
anywhere in the country it's a milestone
for our country it's a milestone
anywhere nobody's done anywhere close so
some tests are highly sophisticated and
highly accurate at the same time we're
making important progress on the
economic front of this war in a few
moments Secretary of Labor
Eugene Scalia will explain new steps
that we're taking to ensure American
workers swiftly receive unemployment and
paid leave benefits and that employers
protect the health and safety of all
workers including essential workers on
the job working very very closely with
workers and with employers to provide
for the economic relief the Federal
Reserve announced this morning that it
will provide up to two point three
trillion dollars in support to
businesses states and local governments
six hundred billion dollars in loans
will be available for mid-sized
businesses with up to ten thousand
employees and five hundred billion
dollars will be available for states
counties with over two million residents
and cities with a population of over 1
million my administration is also
working with Congress to reply
very successful incredibly successful
the way it's going paycheck protection
program which is allowing hundreds of
thousands of small businesses to keep
their workers on the payroll meaning
it'll keep those businesses open we need
both Democrats and Republicans to come
together to get this legislation
completed and it looks like it's on its
way but we need both and it should be
for people that are working for the
workers and if you look and you see we
have a lot of people that are affected
by that and it's a very positive
development so we have to get a
bipartisan approval of that and
hopefully that'll happen today the
Department of Education is also
announcing the availability of more than
six billion dollars in emergency grant
funding to assist college students
impacted by the cancellation of classes
and the suspension of housing a lot of
people had a lot of things suspended
housing is one of them previously we
waive student loan payments for six
months so student loan payments have
been waived for six months and we'll
discuss it after that may go further
although this medical war has separated
our citizens for a period of time it's
also United our entire nation I think I
can say like almost never before
Americans are moving forward with common
purpose and shared resolve determined to
vanquish the virus and lift our nation
to even greater heights
we are supremely confident in the
magnificent future that awaits the
American people and with that before I
invite our vice president and our great
Vice President and Jeanne Scalia to
speak we'll take a few questions and
then I'm going back into negotiations on
oil and on Airlines yeah please
sation with president putin and the king
yeah we had a very good conversation no
there's a lot of there's a lot of
there's so much production nobody even
knows what to do with it that's how it's
working and saudi arabia and as you know
russia it's well known that we're
producing a lot and they were perhaps
fighting with each other over the
production and the amount of oil being
produced and frankly there's not enough
room to even store it our storage is now
full gonna be very soon our strategic
national storage is i said there's a
great time to fill it up load it up with
oil that frankly is at pricing that
nobody has ever seen before i don't
think we've seen this probably since the
1950s that was with big dollars so we'll
see what happens the conversation was
very good they're getting close to a
deal that's OPEC and many other
countries outside of OPEC and we'll see
what happens you know I think they were
getting along very well we had a very
good we had a very good call I think it
was a very good call we're gonna see
what happens but it was a very good go
they'll probably announce something
either today or tomorrow one way or the
other could be good could be not so good
but I think one way the other go ahead
administration discuss the possibility
of reopening the country when the
administration does not have an adequate
nationwide testing system for this virus
don't you need a nationwide system for
the virus before you we have a great
testing system we have the best right
now the best testing system in the world
but there are certain sections right now
there are certain sections in the
country that are in phenomenal shape
already other sections are coming online
other sections are going down and we in
addition to that are giving out millions
of tests and every day we're doing it
exponentially we're picking up and what
we'll be doing in the very near future
is going to certain areas of our country
and do massive testing it's not
necessary but it would be a good thing
to have
president to make sure people are safe
going back to work you don't want to
send people back to the workplace we
want to have it and we're going to see
if we have it you need it no is it a
nice thing to do yes we're talking about
325 million people and that's not going
to happen as you can imagine and nope it
would never happen with anyone else
either other countries do it but they do
it in a limited form we'll probably be
the leader of the pack well I think the
economy is going to do very well now
that's just my feeling it's a strong
feeling I've had good proper feelings
about a lot of things over the years and
I think we're going to do well we're
doing very sly queer at the lower end of
the curb in terms of death which is a
terrible word a terrible dark word that
we've experienced like nobody has ever
seen before in this country I mean we're
we're have numbers that are terrible but
when you look at the lower levels of a
hundred lower prediction levels of a
hundred hundred and twenty thousand to
two hundred and twenty thousand or if we
did nothing up to 2.2 million people
we're looking at a much lower level than
the level of I hope than the level of a
hundred thousand so we're gonna see
we're going to have to you can never you
can never do anything about the people
that lost their loved ones and loved
their lost their friends and I mean the
great friendships and I'm not sure a lot
of people will ever be the same but I
think our country from an economic
standpoint will end up being stronger
than ever we have tremendous stimulus we
have tremendous stimulus plans we have
things in the works that are going to
really I think far the country I think
that what's going to happen is we're
going to have a Big Bounce rather than a
small bounce but we will be back and I
think honestly I think our country is
going to be back from an economic
standpoint again you can never replace
the people that were lost and to their
families certainly you can never do a
thing like that but we will have
succeeded in many ways
hopefully keeping the number way below
our minimum numbers and also from an
economic standpoint you know we met with
the mental health people today and that
takes a trim this has taken a tremendous
toll mentally on a lot of people and I
think we're going to open up strong I
think we're going to open up very
successfully and I'd like to say even
more successfully than before please
about twenty three dollars a barrel
you're what would you want to see the
price do you wanted it thirty forty
fifty dollars a beer well I I want to
see it where there's a certain market
but I also don't want I don't want to
see it where people are have no idea you
know we're opening up we'll be opening
up areas for storage of oil massive
areas for storage of oil because oil
today is not selling and what happened
is the virus knocked out forty percent
of the market immediately you know that
you know the number forty percent now
there was a lot of oil but it was very
controllable all of a sudden they lost
forty percent you look at the road you
look at the car you look at what's going
on there's nobody driving there's no
reason for it right now that'll start
coming back but we are storing millions
of barrels of oil that nobody thought
would even be possible frankly ships
turned out to be a good business for
some people because they're filling up
tankers sending them out to sea and not
saying where to go they're just sitting
out there loaded up with oil so we want
to save our energy in this country we
want to make sure that our energy
companies businesses and employees
workers remain strong so that's how I'm
involved and I think that's gonna happen
so right now if you look you're probably
talking twenty three twenty five if they
announced a deal we can get it up we
need a minimum number so the companies
don't go out of business so they're not
going to lay off all of these energy
workers who are important to our country
and you know we're now energy
independent we could do something well
we only used our oil but I think the
long-term benefit is to be able to just
go with the market and it's gonna work
out it's all going to work out if you
looked at three weeks ago as you know as
we talked about it three weeks ago and
two weeks ago
this was catastrophic I think it's
really hitting bottom and I think that I
mean we've had a bottom but now at
twenty three dollars and twenty five
dollars and probably heading up at the
same time we save our energy and we also
produce great cheap energy and we save
our jobs yeah their banks don't know how
to access this money they're trying to
apply they can't figure it out
so where does the fault line is a lot
with the banks I don't think there's a
fault with they're doing record numbers
of dollars they're dealing with many
community banks they're dealing with
Bank of America Citibank a lot of Wells
Fargo as you know is very much involved
and they're dealing with the bankers
can't go that quickly but I'm hearing
it's a very very successful rollout they
didn't want changes in applications they
want changes in in loan requirements etc
but they are taking billions and
billions of dollars worth of loans and
in the very near future the banks will
be relieving the money they'll be paying
out the money kept please still
expecting the u.s. nca to take effect on
July 1st and considering the fact that
the auto industry is hurting these days
are you ready to postpone the what we
have a deal yeah the deal is with Canada
with dealers Mexico we have a deal and
obviously the deal is different from the
standpoint that production will be lower
but we have a deal it's a signed deal
it's a deal that say one of the worst
deals that we've ever had was NAFTA one
of the worst trade deals ever made by
any country anywhere will be terminating
that and the New Deal is a great deal
for our country so that's something now
again we get hit by the virus and we'll
see where that all goes but certainly
car production is going to be down for a
little while but ultimately good for our
farm is great for our farmers we'll be
helping our farmers by the way we have
money going out to our farmers in the
pretty near future having to do with you
see what's happened the farmers got hurt
very badly by all of this people are
eating less from the standpoint that
there's no restaurants are open no
businesses are open no hotels are open
they'll start to come back but we're
gonna be helping out our farmers yep new
Philip Whiteman Real Clear Politics
earlier you mentioned project sky bridge
and we're hearing that through that
project a lot of the PPE that was sent
out to other countries is coming back to
this country do you do you know when
we'll be able to bring a majority of
that back and then are you frustrated
that US aid allowed a lot of that aid to
go out the door in the first place right
now I'm not because we're we're in very
good shape you'll be speaking with Mike
Pence about this and a little while you
look at the hospitals you look at what's
going on I spoke to yesterday I spoke
with the governor of Louisiana I'm
saying do you think we need that extra
thousand beds that were in the process
of building and we are really in good
shape you're not hearing people are
needing ventilators much in fact we're
going to start helping other countries
with ventilators we're going to end up
having a lot of ventilators for future
should something happen for hospitals
ideally to keep and have but no I think
we're in very very good shape we have
calls with governor's all the time and
the governor is in very good shape now
we have helped we have sent billions and
billions and billions of dollars between
ventilators equipment protective
equipment masks we have 500 million
masks coming 500 million from one group
500 it'll be 300 million and 200 million
over a short period of time
now I think we're in very good shape
please speaking of testing some experts
including Scott got we have talked about
750,000 tests per week being needed
before the economy is open can you
address that do you agree with those
numbers if not how many tests per week
do you think we should have before they
come yes I don't like using the word
needed because I don't think it's needed
but I think we're going to try and hit a
number like that that's a very high
number but we're going to be trying to
hit it and we probably might be able to
do that please go ahead
that's good Thank You mr. president
today the Democrats pushed for more
rescue money for States and hospitals
which are complaining that they needed
to fight the corona virus pandemic do
you think hospitals and states need this
money what you saw I do and I do support
something but I support it for the next
phase it's much simpler in the next
phase whether that phase is
infrastructure or whatever so I'm gonna
leave you now with Mike Pence and with
you gene Scalia and if you would I look
forward to seeing you tomorrow we'll see
you tomorrow
we have a lot of I think a lot of very
big news to report we've had a
tremendous day between I believe what's
happening with the energy industry and I
believe what's happening with Airlines I
look forward to seeing you thank you
very much everybody thank you good
afternoon everyone present moment we
have now cleared more than two million
tests across the country and and I'm
pleased to report we're testing more
than a hundred thousand people a day now
but we're we're working around the clock
to scale up the new types of tests that
the FDA has approved in record time and
every American can be confident that
we'll continue to build out that
structure going forward for the weeks
ahead and the months ahead at the
present moment there's more than 450,000
Americans who have tested positive for
the corona virus and sadly more than
16,000 Americans have lost their lives
and as president Trump just said our
hearts go out to the families that have
lost loved ones and I want to assure you
that all of us working at every level
understand these are not numbers these
are lives and our heartfelt condolences
during this heartbreaking week go out to
every American family that's lost a
loved one to the coronavirus it has been
a difficult week but as dr. Burks will
reflect in just a few moments
as we look at the data literally on a
county-by-county basis every day we
continue to see evidence that that in
areas where the epidemic has impacted
most the Greater New York City area
Louisiana the Detroit Metro the Denver
Metro we continue to see evidence of
stabilization and and it appears as dr.
Byrd suggests that we are we are close
to the peak in each of those areas so
impacted we also express gratitude and
appreciation for the people of
California in Washington State who
continue to be low and steady in the
number of cases that are emerging there
we're watching the Chicago metro area or
watching the Boston metro area and as
dr. Burks will discuss we we just
continue to urge every American to put
into practice the president's
coronavirus guidelines because all
evidence indicates from the west coast
to what we're beginning to see in major
outbreak areas on the East Coast it's
working America and it's working because
you're doing it and we encourage you
onward in that today the White House
coronavirus that task force met but most
of the team also met with Republicans
and Democrats in two separate conference
calls of the United States Senate
Secretary minuchin our health experts
Admiral Paul of check dr. Hahn and
joined us as we discussed a broad range
of issues the Treasury secretary touched
on the paycheck protection program now
in a day five reporting 125 billion
dollars has been approved so far 30,000
new individual users and thirty-nine
hundred lenders are participating we
also discussed that Treasury Department
will issue a a new frequently asked
question document tonight an FAQ as
they're known to clarify how seasonal
businesses
can participate in the Paycheck
protection program as well with regard
to direct payments to Americans the
Treasury secretary assured senators and
we assure every American that we remain
on the timetable where the first
payments in direct deposits will go out
by the end of next week for the average
family of four that'll be three thousand
four hundred dollars in direct financial
support and will no doubt be welcome
news anyone who is interested in
additional information on any of these
programs can go to Treasury gov or
sba.gov since we last spoke I've spoke
with the governor Laura Kelly of Kansas
governor Andy Beshear of Kentucky also
spoke to governors of Texas and Rhode
Island I assured each one of them as we
continue to work through the process of
making sure that we distribute the
resources at the point of the need is it
at president Trump's direction
our objective working through FEMA is to
make sure that states have what they
need when they need it
and to see the progress that we've made
the president just reflected on in New
York and New Jersey Louisiana and the
partnership we forged with governor's in
those states California and Washington
state before we trust gives confidence
to governors and leaders of states
across the country most importantly our
dedicated health care workers that we
will be there to meet that need should
that a need arise the present moment
FEMA reports the president has approved
fifty-four major disaster declarations
and states around the country have stood
up 29,000 a National Guard 11,000 of
which are fully funded by the federal
government under title 32 also speaking
of our military at the present moment we
received a report today from the
Department of Defense that 4,100
active-duty military medical personnel
have been deployed in New York New
Jersey and Connecticut
and they are personnel that are working
on the ground at the Javits Center
working of course at the USNS comfort
ship but because at the present moment
the utilization of of both of those
temporary facilities has been fairly
modest the DoD actually worked with the
city of New York to establish what
amounts to a uniform temperature voltage
and today they literally deployed from
the ship and from the Javits Center
seventy-five medical personnel to
relieve dedicated health care workers
within the hospital system in the city
of New York and we'll continue to do
that we're going to make sure those
federal temporary hospital and Javits
Center is fully staffed we'll make sure
the USNS comfort is staffed but but the
physicians those military personnel are
going to be also be deployed across the
city to bring much-needed relief to our
health care workers in our system from
the VA standpoint we've opened up VA
facilities in New York City East Orange
New Jersey Detroit Michigan and we are
opening up the VA facility to
coronavirus patients in Shreveport
Louisiana
finally I mentioned that today we
exceeded more than two million tests
that have been performed across the
country and also literally working with
the US Public Health Service states
around the country have stood up
hundreds of drive through testing sites
and just this week FEMA and the US
Public Health Service announced that we
will give an option to States to
transition from a federal testing site a
dozens of which have been assembled
around the country to a state managed
site I want to emphasize that this is an
option we believe it gives States
greater flexibility to style sites or
manage sites in areas that they think
are most important but but we're also
processing requests for continued
federal participation in states from New
Jersey to Louisiana to Illinois Colorado
and Texas and we want to assure people
in communities all across the country
that will continue to partner with
States to the extent that they prefer us
to be a part of it with
regard to the air bridge three flights
were scheduled to arrive today in
Chicago New York and dallas-fort worth
49 flights are scheduled over the next
three days and we continue to work
supplies we continue to literally leave
no stone unturned around America and
around the world we're literally in the
process of acquiring tens of millions of
supplies that are being brought into a
distribution system organized out of
FEMA and focused on the area's most in
need we're also bringing real innovation
and at the at the White House
coronavirus task force today we we
tasked the FDA and CMS to review the
feasibility of allowing hospital workers
to use cloth gowns for performing
procedures it was observed that twenty
years ago most physicians and most
surgeons wore cloth gowns every day and
laundered them but it's transition to
disposable gowns and we're working at
very rapidly in the next 24 hours and
we'll have guidance for hospitals and
health care workers about the ability to
do in effect recycle gowns and make sure
that we have the supplies that we need
as the president mentioned today the
president and the first lady and I and
my wife Karen we're honored to be a part
of a conference call with mental health
professionals from all around the
country and we know while there are
families that are struggling with the
coronavirus and struggling with
heartbreaking loss to the coronavirus we
understand this is a very challenging
time for every American but most
especially Americans who struggle with
mental disorders or struggle with
addiction and the president brought some
incredibly dedicated people together to
make sure that they know were with them
early on the president expanded access
to telemedicine and we've also issued
guidance for using technology to remain
connected to social support groups and
we just urge everyone everyone who may
be feeling a motional burden or a
vulnerability during this time
and to to reach out to the many
resources that are there and to know
that you're not alone that we're with
you and we'll get through this and we'll
get through this together
so despite heartbreaking losses that
continue this week in communities from
New York to New Jersey to Louisiana
there are sounds of progress and hope
abounds the reality is that we see new
projections from the experts and if the
projections are right it's because it's
working America it's because the
American people are putting into
practice the social distancing caring
for their neighbors and their loved ones
and their family members and putting
their health first and we just want to
urge every American and continue to put
those principles and guidelines into
practice every day with that I'm gonna
invite dr. deborah birx up for an update
and dr. pouchy we'll hear from the
Secretary of Labor and take a few
questions Thank You mr. vice president I
wanted to cover today not only what
we're seeing across the United States
but some of the testing data to assure
from the prior question if we're testing
I'm sure you're following our numbers
every day and the amount we're going up
about a hundred and eighteen thousand to
120,000 per day are being tested so
we're way over the 750,000 per week
currently we have some statistics that
remember we require this thanks to
Congress to be reported
we have about 75% of that test data in
now about 1.5 million of those tests
have been reported in I just wanted to
give you some ideas because sometimes we
think that we're only testing in the
hospitals that this should give you an
idea of the quantity and the types of
tests that have occurred so we've tested
over 200,000 young people up to age 25
they have about 11% positivity rate over
half a million people between 25 and 45
they have a 17% positive rate now
remember
in order to get tested you have to have
symptoms so this gives you an idea of
the number of people who have symptoms
that are not infected with coronavirus
another nearly half a million people
between 45 and 65 their positivity rate
is 21 percent another a nearly 200,000
between 65 and 85 22 percent positive
and a small group of about 30 plus
thousand individuals over 85 and they
have a 24 percent positivity rates and
so this gives you an idea of we're
testing throughout all age categories I
see a lot of men in the audience today I
just want to remind them about the
importance of health care of the
male-female ratio 56% of the people who
are tested are female 16 percent
positive 44 percent male 23 percent
positive so again it gives you an idea
about how men often don't present in the
healthcare delivery system until they
have greater symptomatology this is to
all of our men out there no matter what
age group if you have symptoms you
should be tested and make sure that you
are tested
we appreciate you engaging in that and
also really recognizing on the issues
about comorbidities and making sure that
we're addressing those I had a series of
great calls with um about 17 states that
are in our more rural areas specifically
around our indigenous people and tribal
nations is a very reassuring call and
you know we are testing across the
country we do have about 63% of states
that have less than 10% positive despite
significant testing and within the
indigenous peoples and tribal nations
they're seeing the same thing that we're
seeing across the nation increase issues
are wrong those with comorbidities and
those of elderly but also issues in
nursing homes and so we're really they
are testing many of these states are
still capable of doing full contact
tracing and so they've been doing
contact tracing from nursing home
outbreaks and other outbreaks it really
gives us a clear impression of no matter
what we do in the future we need to
really ensure that nursing homes have
Sentinel surveillance so what do I mean
by that that we're actively testing in
nursing homes both the residents and the
workers at all times
that is where and that's how we saw this
at the beginning that's what we saw in
Washington State and that's what we're
seeing in many of the states that have
very low case attack rates the other
thing that I want to leave you with I
mean we certainly know how desperate and
difficult the situation has been in New
York over the last few weeks and we've
been telling and and talking about how
this would be the week that would be
most difficult because of the large
proportion of cases that are coming from
the New York metro area what's been
encouraging to us those early states
outside of Washington in California
which still have extraordinarily low
attack rates because of their level of
mitigation all of the new areas that are
having new increase in cases we talked
about them yesterday Washington and
Baltimore and the Philadelphia metro
area that includes Camden Wilmington and
the counties around Philadelphia we're
seeing that the case number is what
we'll get to as far as attack rates we
talked about one in seven in a thousand
in New York that are being measured
these are coming in even with their
progress up their curve in the one to
two per thousand range showing that when
you start mitigation early it has a very
different impact all of this data is
coming together the testing rates the
SERO positivity the age groups who
really needs hospitalization ICU the
innovative pieces coming from we heard a
great report from Louisiana this morning
on the phone call where they talked
about a minimum now a 40% of people
coming off of ventilators alive and
leaving the hospital this is very
encouraging to us I'm really shows
amazing progress clinically at each of
these Hospital
the real lessons what we're learning and
sharing across hospitals but really
shows us that the original outbreaks
were very large but the newer ones that
we talked about in Washington and while
Philadelphia and Baltimore it looks like
their attack rates and the tock rates in
Denver and some of these other states
that we have been talking about are much
lower than New York and New Jersey and
this gives us hope about really
understanding how to integrate this
information together not dealing with a
model but the real-life cases that are
occurring and understanding how to move
forward together to really have a
different future so thank you very much
thank you very much mr. vice president
so just reflecting about what we've been
doing over the last few days remember
last weekend when we made the forecast
that this would really be a bad week as
I mentioned yesterday and the day before
it is in the sense of deaths a bad week
in fact every day this seems to be a
record of number of deaths compared to
the day before in fact New York today
had again another record of I think the
city itself was about eight hundred and
twenty plus deaths but what we were
predicting with the increase and the
real adherence to the physical
separation the guidelines that the vice
president talks about the physical
separation at the same time as we're
seeing the increase in deaths we're
seeing rather dramatic decrease in the
need for hospitalizations like I think
yesterday was something like 200 new
hospitalizations and it's been as high
as 1400 at any given time so that is
going in the right direction I say that
and I always remind myself when I say
that that means that what we are doing
is working and therefore we need to
continue to do it I know I sound like a
broken record that's good I want to
sound like a broken record let's just
keep doing it I get questions a lot dr.
Burks and I about these numbers the
projections that you went from 100,000
200,000 now down
to 60,000 that's a sign that when as I
keep saying when you take the data you
have and you reinsert it into the model
the model modifies data is real model is
hypothesis okay so that's what you have
to do and that's what I think we're
seeing the other thing that some just
broad general good news from the
standpoint of a scientific standpoint
that there are a lot of candidate
potential therapeutics that are going
into clinical trials now that we're
sponsoring at the NIH the kinds of
clinical trials that will give us the
answer are they safe are they effective
and just what is the the capability of
using them under what circumstances as
prophylaxis as treatment in early
disease in late disease so as the time
goes by and we have the public health
measures to try and contain this we're
doing an awful lot from a scientific
standpoint so that when we do get to
next year next fall next winter
hopefully we'll have something that we
can offer in addition to the very
important public health measures so I'll
be happy to answer questions later mr.
vice president thank you and thanks to
the task force of course thanks to the
president for his leadership the
important public health measures that
have been discussed so much in these
briefings in this room have had a large
impact in American workplaces we saw
that again today as the Labor Department
released figures showing that six point
six million new unemployment claims were
filed last week we're all mindful the
president mentioned this that the
American people are making it difficult
sacrifices that is included being
furloughed laid off or heading uh having
a small business struggle that set
American workers can be encouraged by
how swiftly and comprehensively the
President and Congress have responded
three weeks ago the US had never had a
law requiring paid sick leave in US
companies
but three weeks ago the president signed
a family's first coronavirus response
Act which did provide paid sick leave as
well as expanded family and medical
leave for employees at small businesses
with those small businesses being
reimbursed dollar for dollar for having
provided that leave last week with the
Labor Department issued rules to
implement but these leave requirements
of the families first act and we've been
in near constant contact with employers
and employees to help them understand
the law and in a number of cases already
to help workers get the lead that they
were entitled to another unprecedented
benefit for workers was provided in the
cares act less than two weeks ago
that laws you know includes a $600 a
week plus up to unemployment benefits
that are provided by the states we have
millions of unemployed Americans who are
making a sacrifice for our national
well-being these bonus payments and
their unprecedented the government has
never provided a plus up unemployment
pay them like this these payments are
intended to make those workers whole as
mere we can this temporary benefit is
available not just to employees but also
to the self-employed and gig economy
workers before the President signed the
cares act gig workers independent
contractors were not available for
unemployment compensation today they are
at the department our team has worked
day and night to enable states to make
this benefit available I'm pleased that
a number of states are now making those
$600 additional weekly payments more
states will follow in the coming days
how long it takes will vary by States
some systems some states systems will
take longer but we at the Department
will continue support them we have
already dispersed half a billion dollars
to stage to help them with their systems
and making these payments we have
another half a billion dollars that
we're ready to release and for workers
who don't get this benefit when its
first do them the states will be able to
catch them up later when their computer
systems are able to make these payments
let me add that we're also mindful at
the Labor Department that many Americans
remain in the workplace including on the
front lines in our hospitals as well as
our emergency responders my department's
Occupational Safety and Health
Administration or OSHA has been
providing guidance to employers and
employees on coronavirus since the early
days of this health emergency we are
fielding and responding to calls from
workers worried about their health and
sometimes from workers who believe
they've been illegally disciplined by
their employer for expressing health
concerns we will not tolerate
retaliation OSHA will continue to work
with workers and employers to keep
workplaces safe using all the tools
available to us including enforcement if
needed I wanted to finish by commenting
on the Paycheck protection program which
we heard about earlier run by the Small
Business Administration this of course
is loans to small businesses to enable
them to meet certain costs including
utilities rent and most important from
my perspective the payroll as you know
if these companies receiving the loans
keep their workers on a pay low on
payroll these loans are largely
forgivable here's why that program is so
important from my perspective we're
seeing unemployment filings right now of
a like that we've never seen before but
these numbers aren't the result of an
underlying weakness to our economy our
economy has been vibrant incredibly
strong just weeks ago if as we've heard
again today if we are disciplined now
and adhere carefully to the guidance
being provided by health authorities
we'll get that economy back the
president spoke at the State of the
Union of the blue collar boom we are
experiencing we want to lay the
groundwork now for a
you collar bounce back we'll get there
in part by helping companies hold on to
their workers which is what the Paycheck
protection program does keep them on
payroll so that when businesses are
ready to reopen they have the workers
they need and Americans have jobs we
will continue at the department I know
here at the White House to be laser
focused on American workers and jobs
until this is done so thank you very
much great we'll take a few questions
[Music]
just to clarify on the federal funding
for testing sites in the state are you
saying that federal funding will remain
for those sites and will it remain at
its current levels it's not merely
federal funding but in many cases we
provided personnel from the US Public
Health Service and also flowed supplies
personal protective equipment that was
required for some of the early forms of
testing but it's less required today
with new formats for testing but it's
it's it is an option and as I've made
clear to several governor's we'll we'll
continue to partner with our state's but
I have to tell you that the way states
step forward with the concept of
drive-through and community-based
testing is really inspiring for our part
working with FEMA and our great team at
the US Public Health Service we've stood
up some nearly 50 different
drive-through test sites around the
country but literally there are hundreds
that have been deployed by States and by
hospitals and local health care
providers but in this instance we we
wanted to at least give them the option
to take control of that but we'll
continue to resource them with personnel
supplies and and any other support that
they need going forward and of I'm
curious did you see this
none of the CDC in South Korea today
this shows that they're seeing evidence
of reinfection and some people who had
been cured of corona virus and what does
that mean for our understanding office
I'm not aware of what you're speaking
about now but clearly they have been
anecdotal mentioning of what appear to
be reinfection you have to really be
very careful when you say reinfection
because what some and and we were
dealing with this with even Ebola back
during the Ebola time that someone might
still when that someone does a test on
them do a PCR on a body fluid of some
sort and be able to detect what are
likely nucleotides that are not
replication competent so if you're
selling if you're telling me which I
don't think they're saying that someone
has coronavirus disease they get sick
it's documented they get better and then
a month or so later they get sick with
documented coronavirus disease I don't
think that's what they're saying but I
don't want to jump the gun on it until I
see the data yeah well yeah we're
reactivating what means is that it
depends what you mean by reactivating or
if someone clearly is ill and they have
virus isolated from them that you may
have a prolonged course I'd like to see
how long they they reactivate I mean if
they were sick and had documented virus
and then three months later they had
documented virus is that reactivation or
is that infection with another virus i
I'd like to see the data before I really
comment on that with dr. Burks and the
other public health experts on Tuesday
understand can you discuss what is the
medical criteria thank you guys are
discussing in order to reopen the
government where's the medical
retirement criteria well it's less
medical criteria than it is public
health criteria and that is and and I
think it's really important because
often people say
reopen the government like it's a light
switch that goes on and off for the
entire country we have a very large
country with really different patterns
of disease and outbreaks in different
parts of the country so it's not going
to be a one-size-fits-all
it's going to be what is the kinetics of
an outbreak is that on the way down is
that essentially out is it's still
smoldering and possibly going up I think
you're gonna have to take it
individually what would you like to see
yeah well I I will allow dr. Burks to
come up with just my own opinion I don't
think they're gonna be benchmarks that
are gonna be consistent from one to the
other for example I would not want to
pull back at all in New York until I was
clear that that curve really was doing
what we've seen in other countries a
very steep decline down and we had the
capability if there was a resurgence of
having everything in place to be able to
do the containment as opposed to
struggling with mitigation with what
we've been doing that's different than a
relatively smaller city town or whatever
you in the Midwest or mountain regions
which is generally very well controlled
what I would want to see do we have the
capability of doing the isolation
contact tracing and suppression of it so
it really varies differently so I don't
think there's one medical criteria but
Deb if you want to speak it's what I
tried to cover in the representation I
gave in talking to the 17 states that
have indigenous populations and tribal
nations and discussing with them what
they were doing generally and what they
were doing specifically through the
Indian Health Service they discussed the
ability to find new cases and doing full
contact tracing and so they are they
have strike teams they are very well
organized you don't hear about them
every day and I read thats why I wanted
to call them out they are really doing
amazing work at their public health
institutions with their governors and
their
and they really they are in full contact
tracing yes they're doing social
distancing but they're also doing full
contact tracing and understanding all
aspects of their epidemic so we're
looking at those pieces as well as when
I was talking about blunting really when
you're starting to go up that curve
having that unbelievable blunting where
you only get evident attack rates and I
want to be very clear about that when we
see cases these are symptomatic that
have been diagnosed there's clearly we
believe people we don't see and that's
why the antibody test is going to be
helpful to us to really define that so
those are the pieces that we're bringing
together to really analyze that I did
want to say the president talks about
the hundred and fifty plus countries
that are in experience what we're
experienced I just wanted to do a call
out we have Americans around the world
in every embassy that are working with
those countries now this scarf came from
Africa
it's one of my public health colleagues
there I just want to recognize the
public health colleagues around the
world who are doing all of this work
together to change the course in their
epidemics in every single country around
the globe another question if I can but
in response for that just so you know
what the president's tasked us to do is
there's a number of working groups and
that are that are looking at not only
how do we how do we reopen the country
but how do we stay open and as and I
think most of America knows that no one
wants to reopen America more than
President Donald Trump but the
president's told us we need to do it
responsibly and we're going to follow
the data we're literally following the
data on a county-by-county basis this
morning we were literally presented with
information of each county that had more
than a hundred new cases and had well
you know and went in the other direction
had you know
less than a hundred than the day before
it's it's really remarkable and so I
think what you hear the health experts
saying will inform the president's
decision and timing but make no mistake
about it
that the best thing we can do to reopen
America is put the coronavirus behind us
to reach the to reach the end of that
curve with as little loss of life or
hardship as possible to have in place
that we soon believe we will the kind of
therapeutics I call them medicines that
make you feel better by this summer and
to have more widespread testing that
we're scaling up each and every day and
also to have the kind of guidance that
the CDC is even now developing for
businesses large and small for families
and for schools for that day that we do
reopen America question touches on this
question of when to lean back on
mitigation there is a study out of Los
Alamos this week that I hope you've seen
it's on the CDC website it looks at this
question of or not which is a technical
term that you understand it has to do
with the reproductive rate of the virus
the study shows that if the are not for
coronavirus isn't between two and three
as have been thought before it's
actually closer to six which means that
one person on average is infecting six
others so with this information how does
that impact a model how can you begin to
think about when to reopen society if
it's more contagious than we thought
before well I can tell you is the
layperson on the stage we have known
from the beginning that this is at least
three times more contagious than the flu
and I believe that that fact alone has
informed our projections and the
modeling but now I'll let the experts
respond well tag-team together so when
we've been talking about the
asymptomatic group and that's why I gave
you that testing data where 11 percent
of young people under 25 were positive
many of them very low-grade symptoms
what we will be triangulating for you is
the testing data with
fiddling missions and then you'll be
able to start seeing spectrum of disease
because what you're not seeing in
spectrum of disease is people who never
even think that this is something
significant that what they have we're
seeing the significant cases when
testing you can see that we're getting a
lot of people in with symptoms aren't
positive and so really finding out what
is the are not is it six is it five and
the only way to do that at this point
right now is to get the antibody tests
out there and go into these places that
had significant disease when we talk
about attack rates of seven per thousand
like New York and five four thousand in
New Jersey and test the healthcare
workers the first responders all of the
nursing homes for antibody and really
get to your question because right now
it's still theoretic and we understand
they're modeling this and we are we will
get the data to actually look at that
you will see what others have been
presenting so you presented the six what
others are presenting importantly is
they're modeling what's happening with
mitigation and they're publishing that
they are not with mitigation is
approaching like one point three and one
point five so that think of what that is
if it was six and then with mitigation
we have it into the ones that really
shows the power of the American people
no one has varied are not like that
without a vaccine but this is what's
happening with really the power of the
American people Tony do you know to
everything that dr. Burke said but I
couldn't help but thinking when you took
away you know what the worst enemy of an
R nought is physical separation
one more go riding on testing capacity
in the country right now to reopen in
the foreseeable future because the
president talked about two million tests
are we going to have the testing
capacity needed to make Americans feel
comfortable going back into their
workplaces I mean it seems to me that is
a pretty critical question at this point
people are not going to want to go back
to work if they think their co-workers
might be carrying the virus we're not
testing enough how do we know it's safe
to go back well I think the American
people see the incredible progress
that's been made after President Trump
brought in the largest commercial labs
in the world to scale testing the likes
of which we've seen we are as dr. Burke
said well over a hundred thousand
Americans being tested every single day
we have an antibody test that is coming
online Abbott Laboratories literally has
thousands of machines across the country
we're working with hospitals and labs
around the country to activate those
machines for the 15-minute tests and and
we have enough testing right now let me
let me say we're we're we're moving
every day toward that moment but let's
be clear reopening the country as the
president is very anxious to do at the
earliest responsible moment will be
through a combination of facts first
would be that we are at the end of the
coronavirus for most major communities
another piece of that is that we we have
therapeutics for Americans to take
medicines if they contract the disease
another piece of that is guidance from
the CDC to public institutions to
businesses large and small about how to
conduct themselves in a safe in a
responsible way and testing is also a
piece of that and as Admiral sois has
reflected we we are spending a great
deal of time expanding testing today
every single day there's more and more
tests across the country but we're also
working to scale testing that as we move
into this
and move into the fall we'll have the
testing we need to do what these doctors
call not diagnostic testing which is to
take a test of a person that has
symptoms but surveillance testing so we
can identify people that may have had it
and may be immune versus people also
people that we just need to know whether
or not they were they were ever exposed
or and we're not exposed how about how
about one more quick question here if I
can I think he had one right here or
I'll go to you in the back Thank You mr.
vice president in the next few weeks the
Supreme Court is said to rule on daca
I'm about on the deferred action for
childhood arrival and about 30,000 of
those people who are under that program
our frontline health care workers is the
administration in any way ready to
protect them if the ruling comes in your
favor and takes a protection out and
they can no longer work in the health
field as they're needed right now well I
think the president's been very clear on
his desire to reach a solution on that
issue with the Congress but let me let
me say whether it be health care workers
or people working in food supply other
people working in critical
infrastructure were we're incredibly
inspired by the way people across this
country are stepping up to keep people
healthy air rolling and available a high
quality of care even in areas deeply
impacted by the corona virus and also as
we said the other day hard-working
people in our food supply from from the
farmers to to processors to distributors
to truck drivers to grocers we received
a good word that over the last several
days we've actually seen a significant
drop with one major company and
absenteeism we issued new guidance from
the CDC about how people who may have
been within close proximity to someone
who had the corona virus could return to
work before the 14 days if they didn't
have a fever if they tested themselves
twice a day and returned
with a mask but the dedication of people
to continue to work is is truly
inspiring and I know as we go forward
we'll will work through a broad range of
national issues but we're gonna be
incredibly proud for a long time by the
way people all across this country
responded to this moment so thank you
all very much we'll see you tomorrow